lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
explorar cómo los desequilibrios en el
mercado en teoría deberían resolverse
mediante la fluctuación libre de las
monedas así que vamos a decir para
empezar en nuestro periodo de tiempo
como hicimos en el último vídeo que el
tipo o la tasa digamos del yuan chino y
el dólar de eeuu es de 10 a 1 porque la
última vez que las personas
intercambiaron estas monedas el
intercambio fue justo de 10 one por
dólar
ok 10 yoan moncada y cuando digo dólar
voy a decir implícitamente el dólar de
los estados unidos ahora vamos a pensar
en dos empresarios para los dos países
uno en cada uno de ellos así que vamos a
hablar de un empresario chino
ok así que ahorita estamos en china y
este empresario hace muñecas ahí está
una muñequita y para poder vender
rentablemente esta muñeca tiene que
vender cada una de ellas por diez
grandes yuanes
necesita venderlas
10 one si es capaz de vender el
equivalente de 10 yuan en los eeuu y no
hablamos mucho sobre el envío y en qué
moneda tendría que pagar todo eso
entonces él puede pagar todas sus
necesidades tal vez incluso a los
cargadores en el pacífico y a los
empleados que también son chinos pero
por lo que quieren su dinero a toda
costa y obviamente la mayor parte del
costo es para la fabricación de esa
muñeca y todos sus empleados quieren ser
pagados in one es su alquiler de la
fábrica o el de su propia casa todo
tiene que pagarse en yuanes así que esto
es lo que tiene que vender en su muñeca
en 10 jones y el tipo de cambio actual
que sería de un dólar así que ahora
vamos a irnos a través del pacífico y
nos vamos hasta los eeuu
estando ya en los eeuu vamos a decir que
tenemos otro empresario que hace
refresco digamos refresco de cola así
que ahí está una lata de refresco y
similar a esta persona en china tiene
que vender su producto en el extranjero
por el equivalente a un dólar para poder
cubrir los gastos de envío los costos de
fabricación jarabe de maíz todo eso por
lo tanto tiene que vender
tiene que vender
a un dólar a un dólar y una vez más él
se preocupa por dólares porque él tiene
que pagar su hipoteca en dólares sus
empleados deben ser pagados en dólares
tal vez los cargadores que usted no sea
así es como estos personajes piensan en
ello ahora al tipo de cambio actual
digamos que hay una así que a esta a
este cambio de actual digamos que hay
una demanda para estas muñecas ok hay
una demanda de 100 muñecas en los eeuu
esta persona vamos a hacer esto muy
simple ellos solo él solamente están
centrados en eeuu por lo que el cambio
actual lo haré para ambos ok a la tasa
actual al cambio actual ok para la
persona de muñecas existe demanda de
cien muñecas demanda d
demanda de 100 muñecas
y esto es en los eeuu por supuesto así
que qué significa significa que si él
puede vender estas muñecas por un dólar
que es equivalente a de 10 johann
entonces van a hacer 100 personas o en
algún período de tiempo que van a estar
dispuestos a comprar las muñecas a ese
precio y vamos a decir también en este
tipo de cambio actual
en en china 50 personas están dispuestas
a comprar este refresco por lo tanto al
tipo de cambio actual la demanda por por
esto es de 50 latas
china obviamente estos son números
inventados que sólo están para para
fines de ayudarnos a razonar este
problema permítanme escribir también
esto que es a la al cambio actual
así que lo que estamos diciendo es que
en china él necesita obtener un dólar al
tipo de cambio que es de 10
así que si estuviera en una tienda en
china o un distribuidor en china podría
vender cada una de estas latas por 10
yuanes y hay demanda de 50 latas en
china para que va a pasar aquí creo que
algunos de ustedes ya pueden ver que hay
un desequilibrio comercial se está
desarrollando así que qué va a pasar por
lo que esta persona le gusta hacer esto
y qué va a pasar en este periodo de
tiempo esta persona de china va a enviar
más de 100 muñecas a los eeuu
digamos que envía las 100 muñequitas ok
las 100 muñequitas las va a enviar a los
eeuu
ok esto es china y acá está de eeuu que
es lo que va a hacer estados unidos eeuu
va a enviar recordemos que ésta está
esencialmente vendiendo las latas de
refresco en china así que cada llaman es
de 1 dólar perdón cada 10 johnson un
dólar así que aquí va a recibir 100
dólares por sus muñecas
y a continuación una vez que obtiene 100
dólares por sus muñecas él querrá
convertirlos en yuanes así entonces
intentará convertir los 100 dólares
tratar de convertir los 100 100 dólares
a están los 100 dólares
en yuanes
muy bien así que esto es lo que acabará
sucediendo para esta persona y digamos
que estas son las únicas dos personas
haciendo los tratos entre china y eeuu
para simplificar todo vamos a pensar
ahora que pasa del lado derecho a esta
persona va a enviar 50 latas de refresco
a china ok entonces aquí está nuestro
nuestro refresco iba a enviar 50 de
ellas a china de esto es desde los eeuu
y que recibe a cambio bien se está
vendiendo a distribuidores chinos
entonces le van a pagar en yuanes por
cada lata en la actual tasa de cambio o
al precio actual va a conseguir 10
yuanes así que cuando se los convierte
de nuevo él va a obtener 10 yuan por
lata y eso nos da 500 yuanes
entonces son 500 joan
muy bien 500 yuanes lo que va a obtener
y entonces él va a intentar convertir en
esto es 20
ok lo voy a hacer en un color diferente
así que él va a intentar convertir la
moneda porque él tiene que pagar a sus
empleados y la renta y demás va a tratar
de convertir sus 500 yuanes
ahora cuál es la tasa de cambio su
objetivo era convertirlo a dólares y
para cubrir sus costos tienen que
obtener 10 a 1 así que son 500 yuan en
50 dólares en esos centrados y permíteme
dejar esto muy claro esta persona piensa
que va a conseguir 10 iones por cada
muñeca así que quiere convertir sus 100
dólares en milliones
aunque yo debería haberlo escrito aquí
aquí está 10
perdón million estas son las únicas
personas intercambiando bienes
comerciales entre china y eeuu durante
cierto período de tiempo pero claramente
este chico está enviando más valor a
eeuu que lo que esta persona envió a
china hay un desequilibrio comercial si
uno piensa en términos de dólares este
de aquí está enviando algo en valor de
100 y el de la derecha algo en valor de
50 así que hay un desequilibrio
comercial neto de 50 dólares ok si lo
piensas por ejemplo yuanes sería al
revés sería un desequilibrio comercial
de 500 yuanes y debido a ello este chico
está intentando convertir muchos más
muchos más dólares en joan que este
chico de acá tratando de convertirlos al
revés no notemos que hay más demanda de
johann que del dólar
hay más demanda
de del one de lyon que del dólar que va
a suceder especialmente si se trata de
sólo dos personas cambiando si son las
únicas personas en el mercado esta va a
decir bueno yo tengo diez yuanes
permítanme convertirlo en dólares va a
ser igual que lo que vimos en el último
vídeo y obviamente habrá más actores
aquí por esta persona tiene más cosas
para convertir que esta otra persona de
hecho si éstas fueran las únicas dos
personas él sería incapaz de convertir
todos sus montos todas sus monedas en
yuanes porque sólo hay 500 johann
disponibles en el mercado
esta persona piensa que él debería
obtener mil yuanes y obviamente si sube
el precio del yuan como hemos visto en
el vídeo anterior tal vez habrá más
personas que quieren convertir el yuan o
tal vez menos personas que quieren
convertir a dólares por lo que podemos
pensar de ambas formas pero realmente
quiero pensar en cómo resolver
potencialmente el desequilibrio
comercial así que tenemos una situación
con mayor demanda una mayor demanda de
johann que del dólar existe una demanda
de mil yuanes aquí y hay sólo 500 yuan
para vender
o se podría ver de esta otra forma sólo
hay una demanda por 50 dólares ok y hay
100 dólares siendo vendidos de cualquier
manera hay un desequilibrio así que qué
va a pasar bien vas a tener dependiendo
de cómo se como se desea verlo se podría
decir que el precio el precio de el
dólar
el precio del dólar bajará o se podría
decir que subirá el precio del yuan
el precio del yuan sube y la dinámica
sería como vimos en el último vídeo este
chico de aquí vendería un par de sus one
ok y él diría caramba en este chico de
allí realmente quiere comprarlo y
entonces lo mejor que te mantenga es
mejor que te mantenga en lugar de darme
un dólar por cada diez de mí de mis
jones porque no dar solo nueve o
finalmente porque no me das un dólar por
cada ocho de millones y así voy a seguir
subiendo el precio del yuan le va a
seguir dando menos ones para cada uno de
sus dólares digamos que esto continúa
por un cierto tiempo y quiero realmente
explorar el desequilibrio digamos que en
algún momento
y habiendo aún lo mejor más personas en
el mercado y demás pero como puedes ver
sube el precio del yuan por lo que
después de todo esto debido a este
desequilibrio porque a lo mejor más
gente quiere convertir dólares en yuan
que johann en dólares el tipo de cambio
varía por lo que se podría imaginar y
solo voy a hacer unos pequeños números
aquí que el yuan era de 10 yuan por
dólar y ahora es de 8 one por dólar
ok 8 iván por dólar esto es a donde
llegamos la vez pasada después de todo
este desequilibrio en la oferta y la
demanda de aquí tenemos ya ahora 8 jon
por dólar ahora cuál es la realidad aquí
esta persona necesita aquí vender sus
muñecas por por 10 yuan que antes era el
equivalente de un dólar pero ahora por
cuánto le va a vender su yuan él tiene
que vender por 10 y ahora es 10 es ocho
joan por dólar así que vamos a pensar
sobre cuánto cuestan sus muñecas
en los eeuu ahora que el yuan sea este
ha subido de precio digamos
tenemos 10 joan por un dólar
por cada 8 joan ok así que esto va a ser
igual loción se cancelan y tenemos 10
entre 8 10 entre 8 dólares que es 10
entre 8 eso es 1 con un cuarto de eso se
trata ahora de 1.25 dólares observemos
que subió el precio de sus muñecas en
los eeuu en términos de dólares y vamos
a pensar acerca de lo que sucedió con el
refresco de cola
por lo tanto sus costos o el precio debe
venderlos a un dólar eso es claro ok
esto se vende un dólar pero ahora cuál
es el tipo de cambio es un dólar déjenme
escribirlo al revés 8 ones por cada
dólar otra vez se cancelan los dólares y
ahora tenemos que hoy es 8 por 1 y su
precio de venta en china ahora será de 8
yuanes 8 jones
así que no te ninguna de estas personas
cambiaron sus precios en términos de su
moneda nacional ningún cambio en el
precio en absoluto pero debido a los
movimientos de la moneda porque el yuan
se convirtió en el más caro los
productos se convirtió más caro digamos
ahora son más caros en dólares las
muñecas y al revés el fabricante
estadounidense ahora tiene menos costos
en yuanes que va a pasar aquí a un dólar
hubo una demanda de 100 muñecas en los
eeuu pero ahora que el precio ha ido
hasta 1.25 dólares habrá una demanda
menor digamos
si por ejemplo originalmente había
demanda por 50 muñecas ok digamos que
había una demanda por 50 muñecas en los
eeuu y supongamos que esta persona que
antes tenía una demanda de 50 latas de
su refresco en china porque era 10 jones
pero ahora que el precio ha disminuido
ahora te imaginas que existe bueno en
realidad hay aquí no era dólares es
muñecas así que ahora debido a que el
precio ha disminuido en su lugar de una
demanda de 50 latas quizás hallaban una
demanda de 80 latas quizás ahora hay una
demanda de 80 latas que sucedió en el
desequilibrio comercial antes en
términos de una moneda estábamos
comprando más muñecas y piensas desde la
perspectiva de eeuu y vendiendo menos
refresco pero ahora estamos comprando
menos muñecas porque es más cara en los
estados unidos y estamos enviando más
latas de refresco no no hay no es
necesario saber las matemáticas para
poder conocer todo esto realmente la
demanda de las exportaciones de esos
países van a bajar como vimos con estas
muñecas
el otro lado de la otra moneda se tiene
que se abarata y por lo tanto la demanda
de las exportaciones suben porque será
más barato finalmente tu debes de tener
algún tipo de balanza comercial al final